[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mejeke tout la voiture
alors les châteaux vous m'entendez et au
bénin qui m'entendent pas ça c'est
curieux c'est pourtant bien des chats de
que je vois là les shadoks ces bêtes qui
pompait pompait pompait pour ceux qui se
souviennent pas disons que c'était une
gare où il ya je sais pas mais il ya en
tout cas un certain temps à c'était pour
clore la terre appartenait à un certain
gène qui était insectes les shadows qui
les avaient mangé pour la plupart le
reste s'est enfui vers les 1 6 ghz
espace à la recherche d'une planète plus
hospitaliers sa rampe on peut
naturellement
et puis un jour c'était le soir on les
avait complètement perdu 2,6 et on n'en
avait plus entendu parler plus parler du
tout mais voilà qu'aujourd'hui grâce aux
puissants moyens mis à notre disposition
par la télévision
il semble que nous ayons repris le
contact à l'eau des shadoks vous
m'entendez
[Musique]
ça c'est bizarre ils disent qu'ils sont
pas les shadoks
vous êtes les enfants des shadoks
mais vos pauvres parents alors racontez
nous ce qui s'est passé est bien à force
de pomper et de repomper dans le vide
les vieux château c'est est usée
décrépit démonte les plus présentables
et représentatifs de la race comme le
chef shadoks le professeur shadow col de
20 plombier avait été conservé dans des
valises dans l' attente de jours
meilleurs qui malheureusement pour eux
n'étaient pas venus
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi quand un ancêtre mouret
on disait que encore un qui c'était la
valise mais dites moi j'espère que vous
êtes aussi idiot que vos parents
prenaient meridian un peu pour voir
tu es bien très bien continuer comme ça
on se retrouvera demain le deuxième jour
de notre histoire les enfants de shadow
pompés depuis qu'ils avaient été chassés
de la terre sa fé pou d'environ 3 1978
six générations qu'ils ne font que ça
ep alors vous pensez c'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont s'arrêter et
peux vous dire tout de suite que puisque
vous avez l'intention de suivre cette
émission va falloir vous y habituer les
enfants de chat de sa peau ou ça
n'existe pas
[Musique]
c'est que depuis le temps beaucoup de
shadow c'était très passé et cosmo
autobus interstellaire s'était
passablement déglingué il avait
confiance il avait confiance vous
proposer parce qu'ils avaient hérité de
leurs ancêtres cette vertu première
indispensable au plus noble entreprise
et qu'on a appelé depuis la pompe
othmani quand les parents pompe les
enfants trinquent sait bien qu c'est
même devenu de nos jours une action de
base ce n'est qu'en pompon que vous
arriverez à quelque chose et tu aimes
sécurité prévient ça vous aura pas fait
bar chez lush haddouk la pompe omanis
inculque eux dont le à condition qu'ils
soient plus il est mis à couver dans des
couveuses pompeuse qui lui donne déjà
une première idée de la chose
sitôt sorti l'enfant du chat d'oc la
charmante petite chose donc déjà tout
aussi bien que peser mois il est
aussitôt pris en main par des experts à
l'aide d'appareils spéciaux pompe au
scope pour peaux grasses et autres on
détermine ce qu'on appelle son électro
pompe au gramme de bach certains cendré
pour pomper rompt avec une pâte ou avec
l'autre d'autres sont doués pour pomper
en carrés où selon des shadows koizumi a
été revendiquée certains même compte de
la tête mais c'est faux et selon leur
disposition naturelle
il suivait des cours de perfectionnement
mathématiquement on pique ou physique on
pique géo propos graphie ou ciné pop aux
graphiques les plus lus et était
spécialisé en sociologie ou en psycho
pop folk
plat d'une ardeur si noble ils finiront
bien par la trouver cette planète
connaissent espère tant le troisième
jour de notre histoire les enfants de
shadocks au milieu de l'espace pompey
encore cartel était depuis toujours leur
devis il faut pomper pour vivre donc il
faut vivre pour qu'on paie et ça ils
n'en disent en parlait le cos moto buste
allure avait été spécialement titude j
on y trouvait par exemple du coucher
pour pente avec verdure contente on
disposait de baignoires pompe
il y avait des tables et des chaises
pompon enfin manger dans des assiettes
qui compte avec couchettes confondent
approprié c'est dire qu'il disposait de
tous les ustensiles à part ou et affûte
sous divers pour pouvoir vaquer à leurs
occupations essentiels sans faillir un
instant à leur devoir sacré l'énergie
fournie par cette noble activité est
évidemment récupéré par un jeu subtil de
pompe au biel pour pau turbiner propos
culbute tout ça sert à faire avancer le
bidule vers la planète promise et
l'avenir meilleur qui est leur but à
touches comme vous savez
et quand aventure le moral des uns ou
des autres venaient à baisser les
enfants de shadocks aller voir leurs
ancêtres ses ancêtres que certains
d'entre vous ont peut être connu ces
journées sur le porte bagages dans des
valises à en scène pour peu qu'on les à
breda de camomille et de divers
breuvages approprié à leur état
il consentait le soir à le refaire du
cinéma et il nous faisait voir les
lendemains promis les planètes
somptueuse les pays pavé d'or et d'épis
sous les lampes ou roissy et le miel
[Musique]
tout cela leur appartiendrait s'était
promis tout cela leur appartiendrait à
condition évidemment que les chats d'un
pont passe et que l les valises soit
convenablement arrosé d camomille et
doré approprié à leur état
et si possible de whisky l'atteindre au
t-il un jour cette planète qu'ils
espèrent tant le quatrième jour de notre
histoire les enfants de shadocks et bien
les enfants de shadow puppets pas dupe
et combien de tous il pompait comme ça
et bien eux mêmes ils n'ont s'avère
désormais depuis belle lurette avait
perdu l'habitude de donner l'heure où
bien donné n'importe quoi
les enfants de shadocks depuis le temps
n'avait plus de temps
heureusement les valises en s'être gorgé
de camomille et des denrées approprié à
leur état débitait à l'envi des slogans
tony sion un château fort est un chat
d'oc qui le portent pas donc shadoks qui
ne saute pas est un shadow pour n'en est
point de crainte qu'il repose en paix
mais aucune planète promise
n'apparaissait car vous vous en doutez
il pompait bien sûr mais il n'avoue ne
sais pas il faut dire qu'il ne reculez
pas non plus et pour eux dans un sens
c'était une consolation alors qu'il n'a
rien fait ni en avant ni en arrière on
pompe ans dans un sens peut-être qu'on
pompon dans l'autre sens il bouge mais
les îles pompée dans l'autre sens c'est
à dire en recul au et date plus non
seulement il ne reculait pas mais plus
aussi n'avançais pas mais plus vous
allez dire dans ces conditions là ça
aurait été aussi simple de pas pomper du
tout ça prouve que vous n'y connaissez
rien car c'est un principe de base en
pompe au logis il vaut mieux pomper
d'arrache-pied même s'il ne se passe
rien plutôt que de risquer qu'il se
passe quelque chose de pire on ne pompe
mais plus ils pompent et plus les
enfants de shadocks se multipliaient et
l'espace lui aussi petit à petit un tas
blanquer alors les shadoks perdirent
aussi l'espoir
sans compter que les ancêtres à court de
camomille et des denrées approprié à
leur état
redoubler de férocité plus de temps plus
d' espaces plus d'espoir camomille
abandonné au milieu du cosmos séance
le chat d'oc à peine commencée allait-il
s'arrêter là
le cinquième jour de notre histoire les
enfants de shadocks et bien les enfants
de shadocks ne pompe et plus et non ils
en avaient assez leur planète promis ça
faisait au bas mot 98,9 136 millions
d'années qu'il la recherche presque
années de pompage et des ronces de
désespoir et d'abatta et bien est-ce que
c'était comme ça il n'irait pas chercher
plus loin la planète
les jeunes à construire est tout seul de
leurs mains ici même c'est à dire plus
exactement là là évidemment il n'y avait
rien enfin ni plus ni moins de rien
cailloux et bien sûr ce rien ils
disaient nous bâtirons notre ont pu il
avait raison car chacun sait que c'est
sur des riens du tout qu'on bâtit les
empires les plus solides mais vous allez
d'y construire quelque chose sur rien
d'accord on veut bien et construire
quelque chose sur rien avec rien alors
là vous pensez sans doute que laisse
passer quelque chose d'excessivement
vite et bien n'allez surtout pas croire
ça l'espace en ce temps là en tout cas
été bourrées deux choses et au de
quantité de trucs et de machins pour
tout dire l'espace n'était pas clair
très espacées il était plein de ce qu'on
appelait l'antimatière l'antimatière
était comme de la matière ordinaire sauf
qu'on la voyait pas quand il y avait de
la vraie matière qui apparaissait à un
endroit il y avait aussi tout de
l'antimatière qu'apparaissait branoux
très droit aux fabriques tulle
casseroles quelque part tôt qu'il y
avait une antique à ce rôle qui
apparaissait autre part mais on pouvait
très bien à l'aide dont ils marteau par
exemple transformer une anti casseroles
en casserole il suffisait de taper dans
le vide mais au bon endroit
et c'est comme ça que les shadoks
fabriquer leur plane mais l'ennui c'est
que dès que l'on dit casseroles été
transformé en casserole il y avait aussi
tout quelque part dans le cosmos ne
vivrai casseroles qui se transformait en
anti casseroles c'est à dire rien du
tout mais ça les enfants de shadocks
sont ils pas mal aidé ap et ils retapent
l'air et peuplent la planète
quand je dis ça je dis ça sans parler d
une forme assez spécial
tout cela prouve bien qu à force de
taper sur rien il finit toujours par en
sortir quelque chose
et réciproquement
[Musique]
ainsi ça y était les enfants de shadocks
enfin avec une planète
les shadoks s'était fabriqué d'or l'a
dit
adam ce n'était pas une planète très
très planétaire comme on en fabrique
maintenant au commencement les denrées
les plus utiles telles que le minerai de
beurre ou de saucisses les concentrés de
casseroles ou de tire bouchon était
enfouie à des profondeurs considérable
le dessus par contre regorger de trucs
et de machins qui me servait absolument
à rien
au commencement c'était le chaos et les
enfants du chat d'oc pas touché mais il
se disait qu'avec le temps ça s'arrange
mauvais calcul car en ce temps là
justement il n'y avait pas de temps il
n'y avait pas de temps parce que comme
il faisait toujours jour y avait pas de
nuit n y avait pas de nuit on pouvait
pas compter les jours qu'il y avait un
don comme n'y avait pas de nuit y avait
pas deux jours ou plus précisément comme
n'avait toujours bien des badges ou si
cela peut vous rassurer il n'y avait pas
de lendemain non plus d'ailleurs
l'aujourd'hui était à la fois la veille
et le lendemain et l'avant-veille tomber
obligatoirement le même jour que la paix
demain où les calendes grecques
pour les heures c'était pareil et avant
l'heure c'était déjà l'heure après
l'heure c'était en corner c'était
toujours l'heure de faire tout c'était
l'heure de partir en même temps que
l'heure de rentrer c'était l'heure de
manger en même temps que leur de faire
la vaisselle
[Musique]
la seule heure qui ne venaient jamais
malheureusement c'était l'heure d'aller
se coucher à ce régime là les shadoks
très rapidement s'épuiser il s'épuisait
s'arrêtèrent et prononcèrent ces mots
devenus depuis
excessivement historique que la nuit
cela
est ce qu'il ya de plus rigolo c'est que
la nuit en effet
je suis
alors il lui d'un chemin
soir du premier jour shadoks et les
enfants de shadow vit que cela était
menée alors il y eut un soir mais il y
aurait-il un matin le premier matin se
levait sur le deuxième jour de la
planète chaque c'était inespéré
la planète des enfants de shadow match
se joue là ils l'appelèrent but dit il
tant donné que bp était le deuxième mot
de la langue shadow vous souvenez
[Musique]
malheureusement ce jour là le tout était
à l'eau on qu'ils avaient crées loup il
ne s'était pas douter que l'eau serait
comment dirais je serais si aqueuse
[Musique]
alors il dira que le sam a sonné ce lieu
pour que paraisse le sec
est ce qu'il ya de plus rigolo c'est que
l'on voulu bien sam à cerner la main des
eaux ils l'appelèrent mais on chat d'oc
duc laisser paru ils l'appelèrent la
tête au château des ducs à la mer du bus
avaient le droit par contre j'ai quand
même un petit peu et de faire des vagues
et des marées et les shadoks rire que
cela était beau
[Musique]
mehdi qui sur le dos tourné
lou en profita pour se déguiser en
vapeur d'eau est remonté qu'on l'ait ça
faisait des nuages qui tombait sur les
enfants shadow qui n'en pouvaient menait
alors il dire qu'il y est un firmament
ou 1 h 1 comme ça au milieu du ciel pour
séparer les au dessus des eaux du
dessous des rues bien un genre de
firmament mais malheureusement il était
percé d'eau tomber n'importe comment et
n'importe quand et naturellement que
jamais il faut dire que ça ne s'est pas
améliorée du puits et qu'on a toujours
autant d'ennuis avec la météo et les
shadoks dire que cela n'était pas prêt
heureusement la nuit fin fin du second
jour château il y eut un soir il y
aurait il encore un autre matin
[Musique]
le matin du troisième jour se levait sur
la nouvelle planète shadoks tout était
tranquille
la mère vague et comme il avait été
convenu les nuages nuage et chacun selon
son espèce
la terre elle ne faisait rien 1
alors les enfants de shadocks dire que
la terre se couvrent d'arbres de fruits
et légumes de citronniers de pissenlit
et ce qui est plus rigolo c'est que la
mère fille ce qu'ils avaient dit
malheureusement les légumes sadok
étaient des légumes spéciaux c'est
qu'ils voulaient vivre leur vie aux
aussitôt poussé il partait à la campagne
pour visiter leurs petits cousins les
artichauts son volet pour aller faire du
ski à la montagne les pommiers en rangs
serrés descendait des classes pour se
baigner mais pierré apprendre à nager
la végétation shadow pour ainsi dire
refuser absolument de végéter les
légumes migraines et oui ils migrent
quand les enfants de shannon voulait se
préparer la moindre petite salade
c'était une vraie expédition il fallait
aller chasser la laitue très tôt le
matin dans les marais il fallait des
attrapes radix et si je mens compliqué
mais fallait des souricières à poirot
des pièges anne n'avait et quantité
d'ustensiles de la même famille quant
aux petits pois on en venait à bout
kalaba de route
l'énigme château vous pensez bien ne
l'entendez absolument pas de cette
oreille et la révolte s'organise
des barrages étaient télé pour endiguer
le flot des pommes de terre et des
artichauts
mais rien n'y faisait le problème vers
le nas
devant la gravité de la situation et
ministre des affaires végétal est nommé
il est assisté d'un vice ministre aux
souhaits betteraves et d'un secrétaire
d'état aux géraniums la bataille fiera à
la fin quand même les légumes
acceptèrent de négocier ils exigèrent
que leur temps de travail soit réduit de
moitié
ils produiraient des fleurs et des
légumes chacun selon son espèce pendant
la moitié du temps le reste il se repose
et c'est depuis ce temps là qu'il y a
des saisons les enfants du chat d'oc
dire que cela était bon
[Musique]
le quatrième jour se levait sur la
planète shadoks et tous apparemment
fonctionner il y avait bien encore que
dg tout réfractaire qui refusait de
végéter mais dans l'ensemble ils
produisaient pour les enfants de
shadocks d'une nourriture en principe
nourrissante chacun selon son espèce
les pépinières produisait des pépins les
doigts dossier produisait des noyaux
les pommiers pleureur pour leur part je
compterai de pommes d'amour
les enfants de shadow dire que tout cela
évidemment n'était pas bon mais il se
disait qu'on ajoutant une deux escalopes
de courson des noyaux ça pourrait pas
alors il se dire que pour la terre et la
mer d'animaux à une 1 3 4 ou 5 bat
l'entente pas d'eux qu'ils veulent
d'ailleurs ça autant justement que toute
la fin du pif technique afin que nos
ambitions qu'il y est aussi dire qu'il d
animal mal d animal femelles afin qu'ils
s'en refabrique automatiquement
chacun selon son espèce pour mon pote du
strict mais la mer et la terre dire
qu'il n'en était pas question qu'elle
voulait pas se peupler de tous ces
machins là et qu'elle n'allait pas logé
chez un des créatures qui se recrée
automatiquement et parfaitement deux
manoeuvres et le vrai ça à elle s'en
doutait alors faute de mieux les shadoks
dire ce sont des animaux et des animals
à notre hymne des shadoks étaient commis
d'office qui pour faire le chat qui pour
faire le chien
les adoptions garder déjà d'autres
moutons garnier de leurs calculettes et
de leurs gigot des shadoks asticots été
convenablement entraîné avec ça on vous
attrapez du chat d'oc caviar de 8 août
yves il les enfants de shadoks
cela était bon en tout cas ça rallonge
est là
mais il eut un soir fin du 4e et
espérons que demain il y aura encore un
matin le cinquième jour se levait sur la
planète des enfants de shadow tout ça
c'était bien joli mais si le jour
continuer à se lever ainsi tous les
jours pour ainsi dire il faudrait quand
même faire un calendrier pour s'y
reconnaître mais pour compter les jours
shadoks
c'était pas ça parce que deux côtés de
la planète il faisait plutôt chaud et
les jours fatalement se rallonger de
l'autre côté il faisait plutôt froid et
les jours au contraire sur
raccourcissait et se rabougrissent est
de ceux que pour remplir une semaine
d'un côté de la planète il fallait y
mettre plus de jours et que pour remplir
la même semaine de l'autre côté de la
planète
il fallait en mettre - alors les jours
qu'il y avait entre on a un bout il
fallait les transporter à l'autre pour
les nuits c'était pareil sauf que le
trafic se faisait dans l'autre sens
évident à le premier jour s'appelait
gady le deuxième but dit le troisième
audi le quatrième but
malheureusement les shadoks ne savait
conti que jusqu'à quatre gars bureau me
ce cinquième jour qui commençait il se
demandait bien comment il allait
l'appeler et bien puisque c'était comme
ça ils décidèrent que ce jour là il ne
l'appellerai pas et qu'ils en
profiteraient pour se reposer partir
contempler leurs oeuvres
on voyage organisé par shadow jardin
avec pain fromage et dessert pension
c'est riche et tout compris sauf
évidemment la boisson
[Musique]
mais c'était pas tout ça maintenant que
la planète marchait on allait inventer
la mathématique la cuisine et la lotto
qui maintenant on allait faire du
scientifique de culturel et du social
en un mot les sites des essais de
civilisation
j'adore chanter dean servira d'exemple à
tour des populations passé présent nous
fait bien que future yaris
sans parler des zones noble projet sans
doute mais bien voir ce que ça allait
donner
les enfants de shadocks ont décidé de se
consacrer exclusivement à perfectionner
leur civilisation leur science et leur
culture au programme la psycho
cybernétique différentiel et des
intégrales la mécanique à décortiquer
ondulatoire est permanente
l'épistémologie neurologiques
casuistique et gastriques la
télépathologie et les tomates aux
communications de masse sans parler des
arts et des techniques libido sexo
graphique et l'impact programme culturel
assez chargée quand on connaît comme
vous et moi les incapacités cérébrale
naturel de ces malheureuses
il avait confiance car on leur avait
maintes fois répété la culture c'est ce
qui reste quand on a tout oublié
et pour faîtier d'oublier alors là il
était doué
la configuration excessivement passoire
heureuses de leur cerveau leur
permettait d'oublier les chaudes à des
vitesses proprement vertigineuse de
sorte qu'ils accéderaient c'était sûr au
plus haut sommet de la culture s'il se
disait que si on voulait perfectionner
le système
il n'était pas nécessaire d'attendre de
savoir des choses pour les oublier après
il était beaucoup plus intéressant au
contraire d'oublier des choses avant de
les avoir appris ce qui améliorerait
notablement le rendement culturel vous
en conviennent
ce qu'il fallait d'abord c'était donc
apprendre à ne pas apprendre ce qu'il
fallait ensuite c'était oublier au plus
vite est un continent les choses de par
mégarde il aurait pu avoir pour les
aider à se débarrasser de tout ce qu'il
ne fallait pas savoir les shadoks avait
créé les antimémoires c'était un grand
machin à base des mécaniques subtil tels
que des poubelles à tiroirs concasseur
de connaissances broyeur à savoir etc
on le prononce chaumières en chaumières
et il récupère est tout ce que les
shadoks pour leur hygiène culturelles
étaient obligés d'oublier qu'en par
maladresse paresse ou inadvertance le
chat d'oc dans un moment d'oubli en
quelque sorte souvenait de quelque chose
dont ils mémoire rappliquer dare dare il
lui disait je peux pas le savoir
aide-mémoire jeter sa danse est le reste
du temps ils vivaient dans les champs il
ruminait de la mathématique de la
cybernétique de la logique formelle et
du calcul différentiel la civilisation
shadoks grâce à ses soins à les pondre
nantis mémoire grandissait en âge et en
vigueur ce n'est que beaucoup plus tard
qu'il prit le nom d'ordinateurs les
shadoks avait résolu leur problème
culturel grâce à l'ordinateur toobin
l'ordinateur était un animal raisonnable
composé d'une partie molle d'une partie
dure
et qui vivait dans les champs tous les
matins il donnait ses 6 à 7 litres de
crème de connaissances c'était de la
connaissance d'art anti 0% de matière
culturelle et cérébrales évidemment
étant donné que les shadoks voulait pas
trop engraissé de ce côté là
l'ordinateur chats blogs dans son
principe reposer sur deux bases logiques
la première lui servait à se reposer la
deuxième était hypothétique et lui
servait à faire des calculs
ces calculs étaient effectués selon la
méthode dite du calcul des prop david
ajouté quand on lui demande est une
addition de plus 2 par exemple il
répondait que plus dur c'est probable
que ça fasse quelque chose il y a une
chance sur deux que ça fasse 33 et le
chant / but que ça fasse n'importe quoi
d'autre de zéro à l'infini contre si on
leur demandait de calculer une chance
sur but il répondait selon le même
principe que il ne s'en furent but on
avait une chance sur deux que ça fasse
une chance de prendre 3 et une chance
sur dur que ça fasse n'importe quoi on
appelait ça le principe d'incertitude
parce qu'il y avait une sauce dont on
était sûr c'est que c'était faux ou
alors si c'était juste c'était vraiment
par hasard ou qu'il y avait une erreur
quelque part
il fournissait aussi de la logique
informelle du genre tous les chats sont
mortelles socrates est mortel donc
socrate est un chat ça le faisait pas
tellement aux shadoks socrates soit dit
en passant mais ça sortait de
l'ordinateur et c'était la dérider
d'ailleurs le chat d'oc n'avait pas
intérêt à dire le contraire
qu'ordinateur s'est chargé de lancer à
passer longvic le chat d'oc n'y revenez
pas deux fois et en plus ça lui apprenez
la politesse c'est ainsi que le chat
d'oc ordinateurs de poubelles qu'il est
des devins le dépositaire des principes
shadoks les plus sacrées donc de la
raison et du savoir de la sagesse et des
arts ménagers
pour les aider dans leur tâche
civilisateur les shadows compte élever
un ordinateur c'était un ordinateur
tellement perfectionné que non seulement
il prédisait l'avenir mais il prédisait
tout aussi bien le présent et même le
basset il prévoyait le passé vous
comprenez parce que comme les shadoks
n'avait pas de mémoire personnelle c'est
lui qu'ils allaient voir pour savoir ce
qu'ils avaient fait laver que faisait j
y ai demandé le chat d'oc et à tous il
répondait hier vous pompiers mon cher
comme personne ne pouvait prouver le
contraire on lui faisait confiance
c'est comme ça d'ailleurs qu'il écrivait
l'histoire shadoks qui se résumait à
ceux ci hier à man matière il y a trois
mille ans nous confions vous pompiers il
ou elle pompe
il prévoyait aussi une présent c'est à
dire que des enfants de chad sommes
venus le voir qu'on aventure ils
voulaient savoir ce qu'ils étaient en
train de faire maintenant que faire
demandez le chat d'oc mes volontés
il répondait j'en suis fort thèse
continuer comme ça car vous allez dans
le sens de l'histoire
de sorte que le présent shadow
ordinateur mans parlant se résumait tout
aussi simplement
je pouffe tube où il ou elle pour
l'avenir c'était un peu plus compliqué
nous tous les matins avant le travail
des shadoks recevait un programme
programme qui d'ailleurs pouvait se
résumer à ceci tu ponds pas vos propres
est il ou elle comprend les shadoks qui
ne fonctionnait pas selon le programme
pace togo lé là on n'entendait plus
parler d'eux sauf que tout se passait
toujours comme l'ordinateur shadoks
l'avait prévu et il ne se trompait
jamais quand tout vous dire il a déjà
prévu lé numéro shadoks de demain c'est
celui qu'on vous a présenté aujourd'hui
bien qu'il ne s'est pas trompé hier
l'ordinateur shadoks vous a présenté le
film du lendemain c'est à dire en
réalité celui d'aujourd'hui
mais comme il n'a rien prévu pour y est
on a rien à vous montrer aujourd'hui
faudra vous contenter de ce qu'ils
vivent l'ordinateur shadoks est un peu
désordonné mais faut pas lui en vouloir
les shadoks en vérité le tenait
excessivement occupé quand un shadok par
exemple avait quelque chose qui le
gênait dans la tête
il allait à l'ordinateur névrose
biliaire calculs mentaux schizophrénie
dans ma terre aboli verbales tout ça et
s'en occupait il répondait en général
par des traitements à base de nouilles
tranquillisants dans les cas graves ou
même ig il administrait des baffes
tranquillisantes et autres
manifestations au tanit canton chandhok
qui n'avait rien qui les gênait dans la
tête ils les tranquilliser quand même on
leur faisons les lignes de la main
il leur tirait les cornes et faisait des
horoscopes il s'occupait aussi de
démographes ils partaient tous les
matins dans les campagnes pour compter
les ai ramassé ce que les shadoks
pendant la nuit avait cru bon de pondre
entre au moment des fêtes il descendait
dans les foyers par la cheminée et
jouait de l'accordéon
avec tout ça il pouvait quand même le
temps entre eux pour tricoter et les
chaussettes on petit chat d'oc nécessite
sans compter que c'était lui aussi il
s'occupait des enterrements dans ces
pénibles cran s'il prenait le nom
d'ordinateurs des pompes funèbres
protesté pas vous a bien averti au début
aujourd'hui il faudrait vous contentez
de stylia mais devant tant de 6 ans et
d'efficacité de dévouement et de
perspicacité les shadoks se demander à
quoi le en fin de compte il servait à
quoi le chat d'oc ordinateur leur
répondait par le truchement de ces
nouilles tranquillisants tranquillisez
vous les shadoks ça sert à rien mais
entre un ordinateur pour savoir ça alors
ils décidèrent que puisqu'il en était
ainsi il se fatiguerait plus à faire les
guignols et à fabriquer du dessin animé
que l'ordinateur dorénavant son occupant
c'est pourquoi à partir d'aujourd'hui
donc de demain plus exactement en
réalité les shadoks que vous verrez
chers téléspectateurs seront fabriqués
sur chaque doc ordinateur l'ordinateur
shadoks étaient excessivement doué alors
les shadoks avait décidé de ne plus
fatigués que l'ordinateur dorénavant se
chargerait de raconter leur histoire et
de faire leurs dessins animés il pris sa
plus belle plume c'est pinceaux et son
petit violon et s'exprima au ct
[Musique]
shadoks il y à chat d'oc shadow shadow
en ce shadow killa il y avait le cochon
à droite du coach a dit vianney la
planète chante elle était complètement
de cash et et le shadow qu'elle soit
d'un côté soin de le sur la planète
choqué il y à shadow que des shadoks de
200 des shadoks avec des pions pas été
shadow qu'avec des shadoks shadoks et
qui servait à co d'agir la planète barre
en us buzz à cannes en entendant ça les
shadoks sur un pays tony mais
l'ordinateur continuer côte achille soda
qu'ils m'aident à cocher et des buts et
il est chaque octet le matin il faisait
chaque hôtel après shadow qu'ils
échafaudent et le soir et quand ils ne
s'attaquaient pas il sera doté guildo
tâche et du gas gas gas me tocache les
chats 2 pouvait que les dessins étaient
pas tellement ressemble où et comment
s'est nettement à s'inquiéter mais
l'ordinateur continuer l'argument tettey
et glomma ticket s'impliquer beaucoup
plus que l'ex parité le plus déjà sur +6
est plus qu alex parité s'est rangée se
consume les règles mondiales et de la
légumes plus de mots
devenez plis tout était parfait plus
tout est à refaire
plus le plus deviendrait du moins à la
c'en était trop
l'ordinateur l'ordinateur et bien oui
l'ordinateur ce désordonnée et les
shadoks en bois ces jeunes et celle
ordinateur ce teaser donne avec moi leur
donnera ton alors on leur conduisit dans
la campagne où il était venu et fut
recyclé dans l'agriculture et les ja doc
virent que décidément il faudrait bien
qu'ils s'occupent eux-mêmes de leur
histoire de leurs problèmes et de leur
destinée
même si cela risquait de ne pas être
très parfait au début chez les shadoks
la vie était belle
il n'y avait pas de balagne il faut dire
d'ailleurs qu'il n'y en avait pas
tellement besoin de maladie les
activités normales de la vie quotidienne
shadoks suffisent est assez largement
faire périr à bon nombre de morts plus
ou moins violentes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et quand ça suffisait pas déjà des
volontaires étaient désignés pour être
prêt pass et office par le truchement
d'ustensiles spécialement prévu et tout
était dit et puis figurez vous qu'un
jour les shadoks leurs êtres chers et de
résistance ils furent pouces d'être
contenus sur les un salon qui s'étiolait
les autres c'est malheureux se gâtaient
se sclérosent s rabot crise
les bons jours était finie savez acrap
et la maladie plus exactement c'est la
maladie qui les avaient attrapé car la
maladie visé dans les espaces
interstellaires et dès qu'il y avait
quelque part une nouvelle planète bien
beurré d'habitants qui apparaissent
étape elle foncer dans le tas et elle en
faisait ses choux gras
c'était une bestioles bizarres peace
corps nu et bâti muller qui avait les
mêmes propriétés rae avantages d'un
abord sauf qu'elle était vivante avec
subreptice ecotel elle sautait le
donnant sur un lot de shadocks rasé dodu
et sauvagement est inaugurée début mai à
prague concert
ils ont bourré à sa rehab hors norme où
ils ont été tellement de mal a dit qu'il
n'en restait même plus assez pour mourir
de façon normale et officiels si on peut
dire alors il dire qu'il fallait faire
quelque chose et que demain matin à la
première heure s en occuperait sur le
plus bref le plus près à condition que
d'ici là ils soient pas tous trépasser
maintenant qu'elle les avait rencontrés
la maladie cosmique fondée sur les
shadoks à bras raccourcis ils ne
mouraient pas tous remarqué mais tous
étaient frappés
gde ce n'était plus que podologie
posologie astrologie et migraines
névralgies viatique et lumbago est à
fébrile et grippaux chez les autres ce
n'était que nécrosés interrogeons sim
aux call use du foie cécité caniculaire
cirrhose du sein fibrose astronomiques
aux disposent plus d'eau devant tonge et
autres champignons de la même femme
le reste enfin devenait vieux avant
l'âge ce qui revenait exactement au même
la vieillesse étant comme chacun sait
une maladie comme les autres
la preuve c'est qu'on en a
[Musique]
si on ne trouvait pas quelqu'un de plus
futé que la maladie avant on peut elle
les ferait tous crever c'est pour moi
les shadoks organisé un grand concours
de beauté pour trouver le chat d'oc le
plus intelligent astucieux et futée
celui-là s'occuperait de la maladie et
les guérir est le jour du concours était
arrivé mais alors là tu peux on
s'aperçut qu'il n'y avait pas d'
examinateurs c'était obligé puisque dans
tout concours d'intelligence en principe
vous avez remarqué
il n'a plus intelligent qui peut juger
or celui là il n'avait pas trouvé
nécessairement vu qu'il faisait un
concours pour ça tout justement on
allait repartir sans savoir
or un shadok se leva et stade
j'adore mes frères faites moi confiance
je me suis auto examiner et en toute
objectivité
c'est moi je
moi mais et personnellement qui suit le
plus intelligent et on biffi confiance
d'abord primo parce que personne ne
pouvait prouver
secundo il ya ensuite parce que si
quelqu'un avait essayé de le prouver
bien lui il avait le pardon il fut nommé
grande intelligence heures générale est
reconnue d'utilité publique
avec ça la maladie n'avait plus qu'à
bien se tenir
le conte intelligence year et docteur
shadoks reconnu d'utilité publique avait
été choisi pour venir à bout de la
maladie
le choix n'était pas mauvais c'était
lyon n'effraie l'inventeur de ce qu'on a
appelé depuis le marteau thérapeutique
et anti bruit quand une mécanique
quelconque aux shadoks mais vous ne
marchait pas ou qu'ils faisaient trop de
bruit
[Applaudissements]
il est réparée avec son marteau
thérapeutique car tel était son principe
pour guérir quelque chose qui ne marche
pas ou qui fait trop de bruit
il faut t il suffit de taper dessus avec
quelque chose qui marche le mieux qui
fait plus de bruit et dans tous les cas
c'est éradique à part son marteau une
autre tête aussi dans son poulailler une
bestiole bizarre elle répondait la
bestiole au doux nom de médecine en
temps normal faut que de maladies
évidemment la médecine shadoks ne
servait assez précisément tard qu elles
restent entourées néanmoins de toute la
considération et des égards dus à son
rang
entre temps elle prenait des bains de
pieds
c'est dire qu'elle menait une vie
excessivement sibari ticket byzantine
bien qu'on la sortie quelquefois à seule
fin de tondre le gazon et de faire la
vaisselle pour ne pas qu'elles se
rouille la médecine
[Musique]
le grande intelligence sur générale est
reconnue d'utilité publique dit qu'il
voulait bien s'occuper des shadoks
malade mais qu'au préalable il allait
falloir les démonter pour voir d'abord
comment il marchait mais je n'étais pas
très chaud
évidemment
[Rires]
ouais c'est pourquoi un shadok
volontaires fut commis d'office pour
être démontée décortiqué disséquer des
farcis et éventuellement guéri il fut
nommé malades professionnels et
officiels et grâce à lui on viendrait
certainement table de la maladie le
malade officiel shadoks partaient tous
les matins à la sorbonne les shadows que
ceux livrés sur sa personne habitude de
l'anatomie comparative et des intégrales
sous la direction du grand intelligent
général flanqué de sa fidèle médecine on
le démonte et soigneusement pour voir
comment il est défait de temps le soir
comme on était pressé on leur montrait
un peu comme on pouvait naturellement il
avait déjà doc qui triche est et qu'il
garde est bourré à tout hasard ce soit à
pied soit même une patte entière sans
compter que la médecine quelquefois
chipait les plus beaux grands sauts
rentrer dans ses foyers
la malheureuse bête la plupart du temps
ne dormaient que d'un oeil
étant donné que l'autre bien souvent on
avait oublié de lui augmenté et le
lendemain on recommençait
[Musique]
on y injecter votre tout des vaccins
divers d'elle que fermeture éclair
épingle nourrissent wigwe à tricoter
pour voir quelle maladie ça allait lui
donner
être malade officiel chez les shadoks
étaient très dures métis à oui alors
c'était un dur métier quand la
malheureuse bête était un peu trop
fatigué par son travail on les donnait
des pilules pour le tranquilliser
ça leur montée où pouvait se livrer le
sua de nouvelles expériences tout à fait
intéressant il prenait son métier
tellement au sérieux que quand il
n'était pas malade il trouvait qu'il
n'était pas bien dans st il se disait
que s'il n'était pas malade même pendant
ses heures de loisirs c'est qu'il
n'aimait pas vraiment son métier et ne
méritait pas la confiance de ses
supérieurs
de sorte qu'en plus des maladies conflit
faisait attraper pendant la journée il
en emporter des supplémentaires pour
attraper le soir chez lui vous dire si
les connaissances shadoks avec tout cela
avançait à grands pas là quand mon nom
c'est rien mais en tout cas ça les amuse
et bien rester encore à étudier comment
marchait la tête
les shadoks avait un sérum tout près
paris sérum terrible qui parait-il
faisait
on verrait bien si malade s'en sortir et
à des fins purement expérimental des
châteaux qui avaient inoculé à leurs
malades officiel insérant terrible le
sérum qui fait réfléchir et vient sa
marque chez le chat d'oc déjà se
convulse est il réfléchissait
et le voilà maintenant qu'ils se
mettaient à délirer être 10 et il ne pas
être conti de méthyle voilà la question
savoir si les plus nobles aux shadoks de
souffrir ligue ou les flèches outrageuse
fortune ou de prendre les armes contre
cette barre et de troubles et en
s'opposant définir cette aide
passionnant plus le sujet d'eads a réagi
serre est parfaitement mourir disait-il
dormir continuer dire rien d'autre et
par un somme pourrait finir ce mal du
coeur et les milliers de choc naturelles
qui sont le lot de la chair c'est une
consommation qu'on espère dévotement
mourir dormir dormir par chance à rêver
mais dans ce rêve de mort quels rêves
viendront aujourd'hui tu n'as
shadokienne bagarre
c'est la question qui fait la vie si
belle à la calamité
car qui supporterait des coûts du thon
l'oppression de l'oppresseur l'orgueil
de l'orgueilleux les mépris bob rédéné
d'allant à coeur du droit l'insolence
des gens placés les coupes et que le
mérite passion subi de l'incapable alors
qu'il peut se délivrer de tout ça d'un
simple côtoya le sérum décidément
faisait merveille tout tissu portrait
tout ça et j'ai mis les suisses ou une
ville honte mais la crainte de quelque
chose après l'amour cette contrée 1
découvertes tout nu le voyage ne reçoit
jamais revenu troubles l'esprit et nous
fait préférer supporter ces mots là que
fuir vers d'autres dont on ne sait rien
ainsi la réflexion fait de nous tous des
lâches ainsi la décision perd sa couleur
native dans les bals ténèbres de la
réflexion métézeau nous voici venir la
belle fille eh bien c'était gagné le
chat d'oc inoculé était tout à fait qui
récupérera donc conclusion la plus grave
maladie du cerveau c'est de réfléchir il
des critères que dorénavant il ne
réfléchirai plus du tout et que de toute
façon ça serait interdite et la planète
shadow qui était vierge haineuse mais
déjà il y avait des ratés la maladie
déjà rageusement ravagé les shadoks
malgré eux périssent pour venir à bout
du truc
legrand intelligent sur shadox était
adjoint 378,25 professeur tad
lesquels étaient assistés de six demi
douzaine ennemis des peuples nourrissent
du moins agrégé d'histoire de
philosophie de janot cologie et de tous
les machins qu'on peut imaginer plus une
chienne de ocha serait perdante
ingénument au nom de médecine était né
désespère et monop et qu'avait délai par
le fait d'ailleurs occupé mais la
deuxième ça devenait tous les matins
pour se faire démonter jusque dans ses
plus intimes ou interstices parler 3879
et quelques jadco médecine et épingles à
nourrice dûment habilités à traquer les
arcanes des us et coutumes de cette
[ __ ]
la nati
mais malgré des efforts des 378 1369
épingle nourrissez auprès sparadrap du
manteau gris les études d'anatomie
piétinaient legrand année des gens sueur
et ses châteaux kuni autres avec quick
la médecine en perdre et ses lunettes sa
marraine maison c'est sadok qui ne se
décrit pas n'est pas extérieur se
mettait un continent à ceux décrits pire
parler de se réveiller le matin muni
d'un le cérébral chronique est tenace ça
les oblige à réfléchir pour le restant
de la journée de façon tout à fait
indiquée intempestifs certains au
creuset souvent même avant la fin de
l'après midi déjà locaux avaient bien
remarqué que quand on démonte et le
malade officiel il y avait des petits
trucs que machin qui tombait dessus mais
comme la médecine de garde qui connaît
bien il nous cachait pas la tête et
poubelles et électriques dowling et la
nuit et ce truc et les petits machins ne
restez pas à temps les
[Musique]
depuis que les chats d'augmenter et
démonter le château qu'officiel ils
avaient bien remarqué qu'il y avait des
petits trucs tomber n'avait pas l'air et
dans les coins mais les petits trucs et
les petits machins eux
restez pas dans les clous sauter à la
gorge de la moindre patch adams qui
passaient et pour la pauvre bête qui
mashala c'était de la maladie et la
médecine en y regardant de plus près
tout neufs qu'elle est évident que
c'était et oui que c'était des gènes et
shadow qu'on avait connue de gégène
autrefois sur la terre et pas des moins
féroce que vous vous souvenez
intervalles réguliers tous les gènes de
l'univers se mettaient tombe on pourra
les acquis du chat d'oc ou tout juste en
dessous des lieux plus ou moins vivante
et s'installer dedans quand un gène et
sa famille a levé dans un shadok de
semonce fois d'abord il s'y mettait
chauffage central
la température de la malheureuse bête
obligatoirement monter sa luge à une
juge inique d'arabie à ce qu'il mettait
les cubitus à la place des humérus parce
que pour le confort ça les arrangeait il
mettait de la bloquer pour lire at il
ironisé on faisait leur salon
s'installait dans le shadow petite
piscine et des ascenseurs et se faisait
des orgies de globules shadoks blocs où
selon les coûts et quand ça suffisait
pas ils plantaient des champignons de
l'intérieur gégéne menthe à l'eau ça
faisait bien mais de l'extérieur pour le
chat d'oc
ça l'était beaucoup moins au bout de six
semaines
c'était plus deux ou trois gégène qu'il
y avait là dedans et des hordes et des
défis nés j'ai mieux vous dit
quand le chef devenait un peu trop tout
y est délabré faisait sauter tout le
bidule est allé s'installer dans un
autre plus grave bien dodu et doté de
toutes les commodités en eau gaz
électricité ça recommençait et au bout
de deux ou trois mois selon la frénésie
génie que tout laisse donc dû sauter
sillage et génie tu continuer toute la
planète
bientôt aller sauter
chez les chats 2 que l'épidémie de génie
de continuer les gg maintenant
s'attaquait au cerveau un cerveau
château saint était comme un grenier
ouazar dévitalise neurones idée des
souvenirs balles soutenues et des
douanes a aisni la pensée shadoks
trophée philosophie et axiom shadoks
bien connu du genre la ligne droite est
le plus long chemin d'un point à londres
pour qu'il y ait le moins de mécontents
possible il faut toujours taper sur les
mêmes
pourquoi faire simple quand on peut
faire compliqué et quantité d'autres
talents bretonne du même tonneau qui
disait déjà doc la marque d'un esprit ce
mais dès que l'on jijel s'installait
cerveau il faisait le ménage alors
décider du chat d'oc de délicieusement
tordu qu'elle était devenu tout à coup
excessivement claires nettes et précises
comme nous pourrions en avoir vous et
moi des jeunes dida gecc la ligne droite
était le plus courtes mains les plus
atteints les malheureux voulait à tout
prix faire simple même quand il était
beaucoup plus simple de faire compliqué
les chats decaux passé dans les foyers
pour récupérer ces pauvres miséreux à
l'aide de l'ordinateur poubelle on leur
inculque est dessiné bien tordues janot
conan c'est pour voir si j'étais guéri
on faisait des concours de tir bouchon
il fallait inventer le tire bouchon le
plus compliqué donc le pouls simple
shadoks m'en parlent certains malheureux
réussi c'est bien inventer de soi disant
tire bouchons a doublé fait en d'autres
essayer de tourner la difficulté en
imaginant des tirs bouteille et c'était
de la rigolade été recalé pour gagner il
fallait au moins inventé un tire-bouchon
incorporer des gens que vous voyez ici
ce qui était guéri recevait un permis de
penser shadoks aient été rendus à leurs
foyers il va sans dire que ce concours
de hautes études qui repousse jeunesse
qui est ouvert à tous nos
téléspectateurs
toute personne susceptible de nous
présenter une invention la plus tordue
en fait de dire python d'autres boîtes
de tournevis ou de toutes techniques de
son choix recevra un permis de penser
shadoks ne sait pas encore à quoi ça lui
servira mais ça servira de plus en plus
les shadoks était pris au cerveau
terrassé de gégé need cérébrale les plus
touchés dont on n'est même plus leur
langue maternelle des pauvres malheureux
se mettait à parler des idiomes et
patois parfaitement à sa batte le
vocabulaire shadoks normal c'est bien
connu avait quatre mots vous disiez
amour shadoks quelconque moi ça faisait
tenir en même temps troyes demi-douzaine
de machin dit one s appeler comme ça hop
de passoire ou toile pro moulin à café
plus ou moins cousins germains la tour
eiffel des qualités la liberté
plus toute une famille d'otto douar ars
comme tous les maux shadow que voulait
dire approximativement la même chose
c'était très facile de soutenir une
conversation mais les shadoks prix du
cerveau
si on les laissait se dire des mots qui
voulait dire précisément des choses
c'était la porte ouverte aux eagles
dialectique copulation darblade qui nous
deux on rediscute et linguistique et
alors là ça serait la fin de la belle
civilisation shadoks et celle de
l'émission par la même occasion les
shadoks malades étaient recyclés
dare-dare par ordinateur pour ce faire
réinjecter les bonnes manières de la
grammaire premièrement et primo tout mon
chat d'oc qui ne veut rien dire ne peut
pas dire deux fois de suite la même
chose seconde nous et en plus il est
interdit d'y déposer des poneys
interrogations d'affirmations
d'appréciation d'exécution ou de
n'importe quoi devant toute composition
plus typé par une passoire
après 10 heures du matin tout génitif
qualificatif que mes notes et foutez
ponant et dont on tue des rapports avec
son complément prend un point virgule au
pluriel sauf si c'est un hibou un jeune
ou un jeu jouable on ne récupère est pas
mal grammaticalement il y en avait
encore des malheureux qui se démoraliser
et ne croyait plus au prince
immoral shadoks de base qui disait pour
qu'il y ait le moins de mécontents
possible il faut toujours taper sur nenê
cela les shadows co s'en occupait tout
spécial pour voir si les shadoks été
guéri les chats de caller faisait passer
des psycho test un shadow par exemple se
baignait les pieds dans le courant du
nom de pus l'autre shadoks survenait
agents possible pour chercher laventure
comme si la fin c'est nul à tirer et
jeannot qu observer qu'ils étaient bien
gardés de troubler mon breuvage disait
l'animal plat leur art quelquefois le
sujet ne montrez pas assez de rage bien
les shadoks ou alors le ramener à
l'hôpital pour un complément de tête qui
troublait mombreux vas tu seras châtie
de ta témérité ci répondait lannion que
votre majesté ne se met pas en colère
mais plutôt qu'elle considère que je me
va désaltérant dans le courant plus de
vingt pas au dessous des yeux que par
conséquent en aucune façon je ne puis
troubler son bain de pieds c'est là
qu'était le piège psychodramatique et
les shadows quo observé
certaines logiques maladive en effet
prétendez que le courant ne remonte pas
le cours calembredaines et billevesées
alors quel que soit le sujet is it on
l'a amené à l'hôpital pour un deuxième
coup paiement de tête on lui expliquait
qu'il fallait pas se laisser intimider
par des vérités apparemment véritable
mais objectivement il fondamentalement
déviationniste shadow cno talent et que
par conséquent aucune façon et puis true
grit à bois sont tus lacrouts leur
prenait la peine cruelle et je sais que
de moi tu mets 10 l'an passé ont
remarqué un haut lieu la subtilité du
changement de sujet comment le régime
si je n'étais pas né disait la new jeter
encore ma mère l'a été le troisième
pierre
si ce n'est toi c'est donc ton année et
me dis pas que tu n'en as pas puisque tu
viens de me dire justement que tu l'as
tu étais la psycho traumatiques mans le
chef de côtes round qu'ils ont rajouté
mais sa passe est de toutes façons de
cliquer plus malade il faut que je me
venge relatifs aux forêts le chat d'oc
qu'importe s'ils réussissaient à le
manger en toute tranquillité d'esprit
sans autre forme de procès que le sujet
était parfaite mais guère les shadows
quoi inventer des tas d'autres psycho
test comme ça à base de shadocks cigale
et de shadocks fourmis mais ça c'est une
autre histoire quand vous dessinera
peut-être une autre fois la planète des
enfants de shadocks ne marchait pas plus
mal qu'une eau l'ennui c'est que les
jeunes s'étaient lassés de mal à 10 et
les pauvres sans vergogne aucune ni
respect pour les shows les plus sacrées
il gênait maintenant les valises à
s'être tant et si bien qu'on ne pouvait
plus de l'ethnie les valises
elles s'étaient gênés dans l'idée de
ressusciter le vieux chef shadoks était
un peu poussiéreux mais tout à fait
présentable
malheureusement il traînait toujours sa
vieille géologie chronique et voulait
commander toute la nuit tombait sous la
main
on avait beau lui travaille comme armand
grâce aux grands intelligence year et à
l'ordinateur on avait des méthodes de
gouvernement beaucoup plus subtile et
délicate et lui perdu déclaré incurable
il est nommé directeur des hautes études
géologiques section transports et
communications de masse le service des
transports en commun shadoks ne
disposait en tout et pour tout que d'un
seul autobus dans un but humanitaire
pour que les shadoks soit pas trop
tassés le nombre de places étaient
limitées une place debout une place à 6
d'ailleurs c'était la même
obligatoirement étant donné qu'il n'y
avait pas de siège d'ailleurs ces places
ont été réservées en priorité aux
directeurs des transports et
communications de masse qui servait par
le fait de deux conducteurs
on appelait ça le transport en commun
parce que les shadoks avait le droit de
se mettre à plusieurs pour attendre
l'autobus et payer le ticket
dans un but de confort et d'humanité on
avait installés tout le long du trajet
des salles d'attentes on communique de
toulouse pour me des voix dans des
endroits où on n'allait pas mais c'était
pas pourtant car les shadoks quand il
partait de sa déjà mais il volait avec
elle avait aucune raison de se presser
[Musique]
pour organiser la circulation le chef
shadoks partait d'un principe simple
tout ce qui n'est pas explicitement
autorisée est strictement interdite
quand je peux par exemple était en train
de tourner à gauche il fallait qu'il
continue à tourner à gauche
jusqu'à ce qu'ils bouffent panneaux vous
tournez à droite
s'il allait tout droit fallait qu'il
continue
d'autres ont sur les routes à grande
circulation par exemple il y avait
seulement un bout un panneau qui disait
d'avancé et à l'autre bout un panneau
pour recul pour le reste les shadows
calais à l'ordinateur passer leur permis
assure communes les plus aptes on
donnait un permis de ne pas conduit le
chef shawn qu arrêter les eaux douces
pour le bord de la route est demandée
montrez-moi votre permis mais je n'en ai
pas puiser l'eau
c'est très bien alors roulé il arrêter
aussi ce qui marche et ce qui ne
marchait pas pour leur demander leur
permit de pas conduit ceux qui n'avaient
pas devait rentrer chez eux ils nicora
en automobile ou à vélo à trottinette
patins à roulettes ou par tout autre
moyen de locomotion dûment agréé les
heureux détenteurs du permis ne pas
conduire pouvait s'asseoir sur le bord
de la route
tu pourrais aussi marcher à pied ou se
faire conduire par nous il pouvait même
jouer du violon si ça leur chante et
mais sa condition d'avoir un permis de
conduire de violon naturellement les
musiciens qu'il n'avait pas de permis re
était civilement priés de jouer de
l'automobile comme tout le monde
[Musique]
les automobiles shadoks et est
obligatoirement munies d'un volant pour
chaque passager plus un volant que ce
coût supplémentaire pour les
auto-stoppeurs non muni du permis de pas
conduit malgré toutes ces précautions il
y avait énormément d'accidents
le pauvre chef shadoks ne pouvait pas
tout contrôler alors il y avait des fous
qui partait en week-end à pied sans leur
guérite pas conduit les games profité
pour jeter l'écraser en dehors des
réserves et triste mentalité
chez les enfants de shadoks il y avait
beaucoup d'autres
[Musique]
mais heureusement il n'y avait qu'une
route et elle était à sens unique dans
les deux sens de sorte dieu merci il n'y
avait pas trop d'accidents de la route
[Musique]
plus tard pour plus de sécurité il fut
mise à double sens unique bilatérales
dans tous les sens le chef des hautes
études circulatoire et le professeur
château cos avaient mis au point une
automobile spéciale du modèle que vous
voyez ici ce qui partait en week-end
dans un sens pouvait rouler en toute
tranquillité sur ce qu'ils revenaient du
week-end de la semaine dernière dans
l'autre
notons ici que les automobiles shadoks
en plus du rétroviseur minéralogiques
légal qui permettait de regarder ce qui
se passait sous l'auto devaient être
obligatoirement muni d'un porte bagages
et d'un porte train notons en outre que
les wagons de chemin de fer en plus des
places réservées aux automobiles
enceintes et aux invalides de la
dernière guerre était obligatoirement
munies de couloir autoroutier
mais cela ap hm il convient de noter
enfin que dans les trains shadoks les
cochettes supérieur était
obligatoirement réserver
aulas zappos ce qui permettait d'y faire
circuler des bateaux en toute sécurité
j'ai bateau à leur tour avait des
coursives spéciale pour et tout le reste
que je vous le laisse à imager de sorte
que le dans l'autre la circulation
shadoks circulait évidemment quand il
n'y avait plus de rétroviseurs nedo tony
de train de souffle les bateaux tombés
sur la route les avions aussi d'ailleurs
mais ça c'est des choses qui arrivent
même dans les pays de plus civilisé
c'est des choses qui arriveront toujours
dans les bateaux et des avions pourront
pas prendre le train et réciproquement
chez les shadows qu'il y avait un chef
des hautes études circulatoire et
accidentelles comme ça lui laisser du
temps de libre il avait un petit boulot
à la société de découragement de la race
chad o'quinn section course et paris
mutuels pour la course
on n'avait pas de chevaux shadoks
suffisamment adéquat
plus exactement il n'y en avait qu'un la
rive est à la fois le premier et le
dernier quand c'était pas le deuxième la
carte
le sirh riche de foot de chevaux se
faisait donc à base d'automobiles
l'automobile disait le chef est la plus
belle conquête du chat d'oc et s'il n'en
restait qu'une oie je serai l'eau avant
de partir en week-end les châteaux
buvette un coup et acheter des billets
j'avais déjà xeed obligatoirement dès
qu'il y avait un shadok de trépasser
automobile mans le chef shadoks noter le
numéro de l'auto chaloupe qui avait le
billet avec le même numéro
gagner le gros lot on pouvait faire
ainsi des tiers c'est à trois numéros
mais il fallait que ces trois autos là
qui a priori ne se connaissaient pas se
rentrer dedans sur la route et au même
moment il y en avait évidemment qui
trichait et qui se mettaient à trois ou
à cinq pour jouer leur numéro d'auto
après une retraite dont j'ai vu
l'histoire touché le pack ce je faisais
crevé un nombre tout à fait honorable
mais le président de la société de
découragement de la race shadow qui ne
trouvait que ça suffise
or le vieux chef shadoks
à part le contrôle du tiers cette raison
il lui restait du temps lit il
s'occuperait dont dorénavant du contrôle
des naissances a plein qui leur donnait
pas mal de temps
le vieux chef shadoks fut d'avis que le
contrôle des naissances s'effectuent rey
n'ont pas avant la naissance mais après
est ce là selon des méthodes
particulières et à lui on pouvait
craindre le pire évidemment mais pour le
bien de la race le bcg confiant le
contrôleur des naissances et
l'ordinateur partait dans l'ue campagne
dès potron minet pour vers des sondages
d'opinion
[Musique]
il entrait dans les chaumières et les
poulaillers pour son et les on leur
demandait aux oeufs nous vous les gîtes
ou voulait pas rendre ce qu'ils disaient
qu'il n'est pas être confié à
l'assistance de la société de
consommation publique où il était un
continent manger à la coque
certains futé disait qu'il voulait voir
dehors avant de se prononcer mais
c'était pas de jeu la règle du jeu de
sondages d'opinion chanel c'est bien
connu
surtout quand on a rien vu
et quand de préférence eau ni connaître
à ceux qui répondait qu'il voulait me
donner un permis de décence
malgré toutes ces précautions
administrative il y en avait quand même
et c'est triste a dit qu'ils rentrent
ton changer d'avis nss au permis
pour pondre 9g des shadoks légalement
fallait savoir compter jusqu'à 4 à moi
mais il y en avait qui trichent et qui
s'y mettaient à 2,1 bas les gens
ignorants et salace sim était tout
bonnement à 4,1 bas et ça faisait donne
au scandaleux c'est que ces imbéciles a
trouvé ces genres de pratiques
excessives en t'amusant salehi m le rôle
l'ordinateur fut d'avis que pour pondre
un oeuf il fallait savoir compter au
moins jusqu'à 10
le contrôleur des hautes études
circulatoire écologique dit qu'il nous
fallait un permis de ne pas compter ça
l'arrangé vu qu'il ne savait raconter
entre 0 et 10 naturellement on transige
à hassan ii sort qu'à partir
d'aujourd'hui chers téléspectateurs
shadoks pour pondre 9 faudra savoir
compter jusqu'à sa tout cela remette en
cause les fondements mêmes de la
mathématique shadoks ce qui prouve une
fois de plus que là c'est psychologique
tout est affaire de mathématiques mais
on ne peut pas parler de mathématiques
devant les enfants
[Musique]
il y avait un nouveau concept qui
devenait absolument un noble
c'était le vieux marin shadow cela était
dû vraisemblablement à usage excessif et
inconsidéré des eaux-de-vie de camomille
dont on le tenait abondamment abreuver
mais ça le prenait à la proche des
grandes marées
il passait dans les villages pour dire
que la mer était en ondes avec son
clairon
il repasse et ensuite pour la marée
basse
[Musique]
il faut savoir qu'en ce temps-là la mer
shadoks arriver à monter et descendre
six ou sept fois dans la journée et à
peu près autant emplois dans la nuit
duflot jusqu'au jugement et de l'ebre
remontant le mara jade up bourré de
camomille monette chabad on s'en
débarrasse il fut nommé grand amiral des
flottes dans l'afl shannon qu'on avait
premièrement les vaisseaux de hobo
venaient ensuite les vaisseaux de bâbord
on avait aussi des vaisseaux de tribord
avec trois côtés afin dé mes sauts de
sorbonne ainsi nommée parce qu'on
laissait le bord à terre pour ne pas lui
si l'un des fatigables celui ci tiennent
particulièrement l'eau s'appelle l'hydro
fils mais il est encore sous coco enfin
toute la série des retournable info
voyants et aux
sans oublier le navire amiral l'écumoire
des mères la principale vertu des
bateaux de la marine shadow qui était de
pouvoir se rentrer les uns dont les
autres avec la plus exquise facilité
c'était intéressant mais ce n'est limité
l'usagé de la flotte schade qu'est la
seule navigation verticale negras à
l'amiral shadoks tout cela allait
changer la vie à bord des vaisseaux
shadow qui étaient organisées de la
façon suivante il n'y avait un tir des
shadows qui plus est le deuxième tiers
éplucher des pommes de terre pour donner
aux tiers qui pique le troisième tiers
récupérer
amag manette ou tout autre récipient de
son show au début ont permuté
[Musique]
à
mais c'était très dangereux parce que ce
qui était doué pour les peluches âge
n'était pas nécessairement doué pour le
pompage et ça risquait de nuire à
l'efficacité plus les leçons quant à la
récupération
c'était un art difficile qu'on ne
pouvait confier qu'à des initiés
naturellement comme les trois tiers
étaient occupées il n'y avait personne
sur le pont pour regarder devant
il n'y avait pas deux tiers pour faire
le cas si l'on peut dire sauf le tiers
récupérateur qu'on mettait à récupérer
sur le pont parce que c'était plus
confort dans la marine shadoks c'est ce
qu'on appelait faire le quartier cela
explique la facilité avec laquelle des
bateaux shadoks se rentraient flize dans
les eaux ou d'autres étaient
suffisamment rigide si plus à proximité
crochet ça ou c'est pourquoi la nuit
l'amiral shadoks allait éteindre les
phares pour ne pas trop pâtir et les bat
le jour il allait les camoufler dans des
endroits sûrs où les bateaux ne pouvait
pas les trouver
[Musique]
l'amiral shadoks avait un plan radical
pour améliorer la sécurité
il avait remarqué en effet que 90 % des
naufrages sont dus au fait qu'il se
passe le plus souvent sur l'eau la
quantité d'eau situés en dessous des
bateaux est tout à fait excessif de plus
les listes des bateaux pour ce qu'elle a
à en faire d'absolument pas besoin des
étendues d'eau ridiculement immense à
l'avant et à l'arrière
les nouveaux bateaux de l'amiral shadoks
ne l'emporté que la quantité d'eau
strictement nécessaires pour mouiller
les lys
ce qui leur permettait de naviguer en
toute sécurité non seulement sur les
mers les plus innocents sur des moyens
excessivement c'est l'amiral
allez maintenant s'attaquer à un
problème shadoks qui n'avait jamais été
résolu le problème du tunnel sous la
manche mais ce sera pour une autre fois
chez les shadows qu'il y avait une mère
qu'on appelait la manche en anglais le
canal pour aller rendre visite à leurs
cousins d'en face les shadows
qu'utilisait defache watts dont la
principale qualité malheureusement été
bon ou peut-être excessivement sûr merci
de sorte que les voisins d'en face
c'était plutôt au fond qu'on avait le
plus de chance de les rencontrer
on avait bien essayé de creuser des
tunnels
malheureusement les faits les boîtes
refusait absolument d'y mettre les pieds
mais gagne un chez nous qu'avec un plan
ce qu'il fallait disait-il ce n'était
pas un tunnel sur le canal mais un canal
sur le canal les chats ne voyait pas
très bien d'utilité mais il savait qu'on
fasse un construit c'est tout simplement
un canal et qu'on s'était fait on vit
des lots les faillites boîtes les plus
submersible tels que prouvait chemin de
fer et faire passer est traversé à pied
sec en toute tranquillité cd simple mais
fallait y penser
évidemment les bateaux qui allait d'un
bout à l'autre de la manche avaient
protesté mais l'amiral leur avaient
installé des pays acp sorte de cadeau
mythe qui traversait le canal secte qui
taxait le canal de l'avant du bateau
sous la main qui pour des raisons
diverses préféré garder incognito
on avait creusé dans le canal c'est que
des tunnels ropiteau il est aussi le
problème des poissons chats 2 et autres
paliers ben crustacés à leur intention
on avait organisé un service spécial de
boîtes de sardines qui empruntait un
canal humide qui traversait le canal
c'est qu'ils traversaient le canal de la
manche qui lui même traversé le canal
c'est qui va d'edimbourg à tamanrasset
malheureusement les sardines n'était pas
habitué les félibres leur donner le mal
de mer et elle préférait prendre des
passages tout le monde fut content et
l'amiral shadoks décoré et d'aller
s'attaquer maintenant aux difficiles
problèmes de la météorologie cajus
ticket mais nous verrons
tous les matins l'amiral shadoks mettait
sa flotte à l'eau il partait écumer les
mers avec son cuir assez l'écumoire il
était le seul maître à bord après le
dieu shadow bien sûr mais comme le dieu
shadoks était toujours parti aux
ministères et que de toute façon il
aurait rien fichu propre c'est un oral
constater tout le début un tiers du
temps ils étaient quartier-maître de
passoire et les copé le deuxième tiers
il était lieutenant de passoire le
troisième tiers et des têtes amiral est
récupérée en préparant l'école de guerre
le reste du temps il s'occupait de
météorologie effectuer ces prévisions
météorologiques à l'aide d'appareils
spéciaux plus connue maintenant sous le
nom de bouteilles si vers 9 heures du
matin
le whisky poney un goût de tomates s'est
prononcé et si en même temps les moutons
d'état vont céder qu'on aurait leur âge
dans la soirée ou du vent dans le
muscadet
car comme disait le proverbe en
bouteille comme en hiver le vent d'amour
se lève et se couche avec les moutons et
silver est isolé mouton était pas touché
que le van damme on se mettait dans le
beaujolais et que le muscadet prenait un
goût d'hypocrisie c'était signe que l'on
tombe répand en pluie sauf si entre
temps naturellement la vodka au mourre
on prenait un arrière-goût de moutons
ils auraient pu filmer ses travaux
scientifiques tout le reste de la
journée pour grand bien de la technique
météorologiques
malheureusement sur le coup de midi
12h30 l'amiral shadow voyait poindre du
fond du ciel c'était pas des cirrus
j'étais porté fruit
dépend du jour d'amour
c'est d'aider des chapeaux à 1 d'ici
obscur ce sens là jure pris l'air on est
infesté les faucons les reculs et pour d
l'amiral des démarches et les terribles
missiles j'ai pu voir l'été d'aucun
effet il fallait se rendre à l'évidence
c'était des chapeaux d'un autre
tous les jours sur le coup de midi 12h30
l'amiral sadok voyez moindre du fond du
ciel des chapeaux des chapeaux non
identifiés et probablement cosmique
en résumé neige à d'autres atouts les
chats dont voici le portrait rambier de
chapeau et non identifiés et
probablement kosslick
tout ce qui vous trouvera n'aura par
habitant
deuxièmement est instamment priée de ne
pas nous leur apporter et de le garder
chez lui vu que c'est extrêmement
dangereux
les autres voyez rien mais ils se muent
c'est dare-dare les abris aux autruches
à plat et tous les jours après les
observations météorologiques de l'amiral
mais shadox attaquer trouvez vous sauver
vous criez l'amiral
et ne les voyez pas mais au petit matin
sur la terre encore molle il y avait des
empreintes de terribles qui aux dires
des experts en podologie n'était autre
que des pieds de chat
[Musique]
yam était toujours et shadox attaqué la
mire
est-ce qu'il ne pouvait pas venir à bout
sur les mêmes eh bien désolé d attaquer
dans les airs avec son est court pour
attaquer dans le ciel les terribles
chapeau cosmique l'amiral chad o'quinn
avec eux son écume mois malheureusement
ce n'était pas juste un signe très
opérationnelle à l'ajout fallait
inventer des fumoirs voulons les
écumoire comme tous les ustensiles
aéronautique dur dès qu'on les laisse en
l'air livrés à eux-mêmes manifeste de
syndrome
c'est comme un type d'éclaicir est
longue icsa les incite les malheureux à
retourner aux badauds les délais les
plus rapides et même qu'on aventure leur
poste et bien il tente quand même
mais vers le haut de sorte que pour
faire voler une écumoire dizaine amiral
consiste à lui mettre son bas au dessus
de son ou au tout tout
à cet effet la pirogue avait mis au
point un carburant spécial à base de
kérosène tranquillisants et autres
additifs antidépressives et
hallucinatoire ont nagé kt echaâb massif
pour les tumeurs est alors se faisait
par des tirs des terrils se passer dans
le ciel
toutes affaires cessantes elle monte au
ciel pour atterri naturellement dès
qu'il n'y avait plus de tranquillisants
dans les réservoirs l'écumoire revoyez
la terre du bon côté et d'antan elle
rate hérisset l'amiral avec ce système
pouvait aussi bien faire voler des vélos
à condition qu'ils aient été
préalablement gonflé au kérosène pour
plus de sécurité il était quand même
recommandé d'injecter aussi pas mal de
carburant tranquillisants dans la mire à
lui même de sorte qu'en cas de
défaillance de la machine c'est l'amiral
qui faisait lever tout cela était
contraire aux principes maritime shadoks
de base qu'il usait la machine s'est pas
passé plus fort il avait aussi à faire
voler des cafetières des jantes aux noix
ou défaire à page et vous allez dire
qu'il aurait été aussi simple de faire
voler directement la murale ou les
maquereaux
mais leurs épaules les chansons films
j'en fais un cafetier auto noir et pince
à linge tout vécu avec son taudis de son
ami ron arrive même à faire
mais des avions qui lui lit mais je
parle je parle de cul moir de vélo vol
devant de tranquillisants et c'est pas
ça qui fait avancer notre histoire de
chapeau non identifié mais qu'on en
parlera demain et ses premiers souvenirs
l'achat son chapeau non identifiés
l'amiral shadoks dit très étonné par des
cubes noirs et lointain et de fer à
repasser d'haruna va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'événement passé normalement et est
munie de crochets pour s'agripper le
moment nous et qu noir navale qui
passait oui
les études voire à leur tour des
milliers d'entre eux marine pour
s'accrocher à la terre quand elle
voulait bien remarqué entre parenthèses
que pour des shadoks qui avait choisi de
vivre leur vie en r c'était pas très
logique de pondre pour emblème lancre de
marine instrument qui sert uniquement à
s'accrocher à la têt et encore pas
toujours spécial c'est une autre
histoire pour la paix maintenant les
faits rares pas si les marins pilotes
que pour voler était bourré de kérosène
tranquillisants ce n'est que beaucoup
plus tard que les uns et les autres
furent muni de roulettes d'elle et
délices et ça uniquement pour faire jeu
d'ailleurs vous remarqué que plus ça va
moins les avions besoin d'elle ou
déduits ce qu'on volé mais plus par pète
il se bourre de kérosène tranquillisants
qui pour une fois de plus que les
shadoks avait tout inventé mais ça c'est
encore une autre histoire
le fener passé d'ailleurs en aval était
un moyen de transport beaucoup plus sûre
signal remarqué que la plupart des
bateaux de mémoire shadoks en effet on
n'avait jamais vu ça on peut rester
indéfiniment au mollet
[Musique]
par contre il était très courant de voir
des bateaux rester éternellement mais
quelquefois plus longtemps et plus bas
de sorte que brit air à repasser bien
souvent ne pouvait plus lui récuse mois
pour se récupérer devait avoir rempli
catoire mans à bord des écumoires de
sauvetage sûreté s'était pas tout à fait
pareil les écumoire volonté perez avait
d'abord les chewing gum au champagne est
mort les parachutes en paquet d autres
pochettes surprises normalement dévolues
à chaque passager mais elle a des tons
plus des canots de sauvetage qui se
gonflent est automatiquement en forme de
terrain d'aviation
naturellement il y avait toujours des
passagers futé qui ont porté dans leurs
valises des terrains d'atterrissage
secret et du tournis mais je parle je
parle et tout ça fait pas aussi cette
triste issement de charnot d'identifier
qui nous préoccupe tous les bus on en
parlera demain ses premiers jeunes et
j'adore les attaques des chapeaux
cosmique non identifiés rassurez vous ça
continuait mais l'auteur de votre
feuilleton préféré ne m'a pas encore guy
comment cette sinistre histoire allait
se terminer alors je vais vous parler
d'autre chose
les jeunes pour voyager souvent utilisé
l'écumoire aériennes seraient toujours
des accidents mais l'ordinateur à des
calculs et convoyé au 218
il y en avait eu d'accident bah c'est du
langage ordinateur excusé alors les
jeunes voyageurs très astucieusement
attendait qu'on ait eue 218 accidents
des fumoirs avant de monter dedans
à cet effet on organisait que les
premiers jo à messine taxi d'origine
noire pour faire in situ les 218 accès
d'entrée on en cash et même cinq ou six
de plus pour faire bonne mesure et on
était tranquille pour le restant de
l'année
malheureusement les shadoks qu'aucune
partie ne savez jamais où ils voulaient
pas me
[Musique]
quand il prenait le train il n'y avait
pas de problème c'était programmé qu'il
veut nous fait pas des shadoks
automatiquement se retrouver à l'autre
bout de la foi
[Musique]
mais on avions c'était pas pareil
les shadoks d'abord faisait la course à
pied il ya eu des pics de spéciales
prévues à cet effet des trottoirs
basculant des escaliers qui s'en ait des
portes d'entrée cybernétique assorti
automatique il y avait même des ronds
biais qui ausculte et vos pâtes et vos
papiers ils se les repasser à un voisin
lequel les envoyer pour confirmation à
sa petite cousine qui était coiffeuse du
ministère des papes et des pelures
d'oignon et si vous n'étiez pas partie
entre temps peut être pas de vous
revenez dûment muni des sacrements de
l'église mais assortie l'obligation
d'acheter toutes affaires cessantes 3
demi-douzaine deux couloirs en spirale
et au manioc sous prétexte qu'elles sont
bien moins chers qu'à nous y sommes mais
je m'égare
ces tests étant pas si on afficher sur
un grand tableau le nom des shadoks
qu'avait le droit de prendre l'avion
une fois l'avion décollé il fallait
savoir où on allait là ça se joue en
trois manches au poker celui qui pouvait
sortir de sa valise un bazooka un char
lance missiles ou à casser toute équipe
est incontestablement avait pas qui mais
je parle je parle et tout ça fait pas
avancer notre histoire de chapeau
cosmique note identifie on en parlera
demain c'est certain
[Musique]
les écumoire volantes les bateaux et les
chapeaux cosmique ça fait depuis dix
jours qu'on est en train de vous en
parler ça risque de vous embêter alors
pour changer je vais vous parler de deux
tuyaux chez les enfants de chanac les
denrées alimentaires de base comme les
yaourts ou la sauce tomate était enterré
à des profondeurs considérer pour
trouver le moindre gisement de chaussure
gauche par exemple il fallait creuser de
très profond puits et le puits creusés
on n'était même pas sûr de tomber sur
une chaussure qui vous a raconté que les
mines de nouilles qui servait évidemment
de l'a7 souny était si quid des couples
est excessivement qu'exotique on était
obligé de laisser venir
par devlin hanul ou à la scène
on aurait pu fabriquer des lacets à
l'extrait de gao que minier mais c'était
beaucoup moins solide que des nouilles
il s'était même mon abo à manger que les
lacets de souliers c'est pourquoi les
pauvres shadow plutôt que de se fatiguer
à creuser des mines préféré marcher nu
qui bien que de 20 pompiers tout ça
allait changer
il avait un truc pour détecter les
médias sociaux droite un autre toutes
les mines de caution cela fait il
plantait des tuyaux de sorte que les
shadoks au matin trouvait sur le
réveiller un robinet à la c'est un
robinet à chaussure droite
d'un côté et de l'autre un robinet à
chaussures les plus embêtés sait déjà
qu'il y avait trois pieds comme le
demain plombier été atteint depuis
l'automne
sénile il ne se passait pas de nuit
qu'il n'ait pu noter quelques nouvelles
denrées de première nécessité et au
matin le château qui trouvaient quatre
nouveaux rangs d'une sauce tomate droite
sauce tomate con dao pts 3 yahoo
touchons des plus fortunés avec des
vide-ordures pour jeter les yaourts ou
les chaussures avant qu'elles soient
accusés les pauvres n'avaient pas de
vide ordures et de maîtriser leurs
chaussures jusqu'au bout et quelquefois
les manger pour s'en débarrasser
certains city faisait coulé des robinets
directement dans le vide-ordures mais
évidemment c'était interdit je devais un
plombier dans les mines à ordures
surveiller cb pas de trucs un consommé
son étude la frégate si vous pensez mais
le moment est venu de vous parler des
terribles chapeau nos d'identifier tous
les jours dès que l'amiral avait terminé
ses observations météorologiques
[Musique]
des chapiteaux smic attaquer
rendez vous soit vous les chalands
attaque rien mais restait terry à la fin
comme les châteaux pensèrent l'amiral
qui voit le japon supprimons la bien
aller on sera sauvé c'était puissamment
raisonnée et avec toute la peau dus à
son rang
l'amiral shadoks fut rendu à sa fin et
c'est là que les chapeaux cosmique
apparu sortait ilonse octets créatures
des bêtes indicible
qu'il leur championnat fin quelques mois
[Musique]
c'était lui c'est un tj byrs
jb les avaient retrouvés
c'est fini les shadows que l'on planet9
à l'épée les jb autrefois étaient des
animaux très gentil avec un petit
chapeau sur la tête pour pouvoir se dire
bonjour dehibi depuis ce temps grâce à
l'achat pour paulo étaient devenus les
maîtres de tous les siens
chaque nouvelle planète qu'il voyait
s'arrêter pour la nettoyer et là
d'épauler dgipi c'était comme qui dirait
des polluants universelle et la planète
shadoks ce matin ridicule ils pouvaient
franchement pas laisser ça dans le ciel
les shadoks qu'ils allaient les
dépolluer les tactiques et les récurer
de l'intérieur de l'extérieur en avril
allait les jib ise et des shadoks
connurent une ère nouvelle celle de la
propreté du corps et de l'esprit celle
de la civilisation jpy les jbe sillonné
l'espace dans les chapeaux
interstellaire les chapeaux étaient
munis d'un réacteur chapeau et le
réacteur fonctionne avec un combustible
chapeau ce qu'on appelle maintenant le
cosmo goal 999 les jbe exprès nord cosmo
gun de l'atmosphère sur certaines
planètes l'atmosphère au stand a été
solide sur dont elle est élue qui sur
d'autres encore l'atmosphère était
nettement plus atmosphérique et
nécessité des appareillages plus
compliqué et quand il n'y avait pas
d'atmosphère dans les parages et bien
les gibiers extrayez leur cosmogonie de
rien du tout comme l'espace en ce temps
là était infinie est composé en moyenne
de 100 % de rien du tout les réserves de
cosmo goal est intimement
à bord des chapeaux l'egypte y avait
installé des moulins archos beau gosse
[Musique]
il y avait des moulins qui transformait
le cosmo vols purs en nourriture ou une
exquise gourmandise d'autres moulins à
fabriquer des graines de culture on les
planter dans des pots de fleurs et
s'adonnait linge audard n'est plus rare
il y avait tôt fait d moulin à musique
qui donnait de la musique sonore il
donnait aussi de ma musique muette et ne
la musique lumières c'est dire qu'avec
tous leurs moulins les jibuls n'avait
quasiment rien à faire de la journée
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça on vous en a
pas encore parlé franchement je devrais
pas des bêtes vous de montrer des
chipies en train de manger de se dire
bonjour ou de danser le menuet
l'egypte y passait donc leur temps à
perfectionner leur civilisation et leur
culture ils organisaient des colloques
et des symposiums pour se dire bonjour
et cultiver les bonnes manières
mais le plus souvent il dansait le menu
et ceux qui chez eux étaient la marque
du plus extrême raffinement
et il fallait ainsi de planète en
planète répondre les bienfaits de la
civilisation jpy quand les givi
débarquer sur une planète il a commencé
par planter des villes néjib y avait des
moules qui fabriquait des graines
d'architecturé on les plante est et
aussitôt il y avait une ville qui
poussait convenait l'été l'avim
fleurissaient
ça faisait deux nouvelles graines qui
sera replanté la ville grandit c'est un
sujet d'un côté mais repoussée pour
faire joli l'egypte y planter çà et là
quelques graines de monuments
historiques
enfin ils plantaient des moulins musique
et quand tout était installé il s'en
prenait aux habitants a tancé le muet
c'est ainsi qu'ils avaient civilisé la
planète à poissons
[Musique]
sur la planète à dinosaures les
dinosaures danser le menu est
[Musique]
les mines est contre on peut aussi dont
c'est le menu est et sur la planète
avait nous les vélos belloc danser le
menu est à longueur de journée et
l'univers entier raisonnée nos excuses à
revenir et aux accords les plus parfaits
de la civilisation chine
[Musique]
il n'y avait qu'un coin du cosmos qui
résonnait mal y avait donc encore
quelques pas de planète qui grinçait
canepa
vous l'avez deviné c'était la planète
des enfants challenge
elle est témoin des péniches ont
complètement raté
[Musique]
quelle était la doublure l'espace de
scripts discordants de toute sa vie dit
[Musique]
elle était là comme une injure à la
belle ordonnance cosmique gigli il
fallait s'en occuper élégie pour était
d'apprendre le menu est à telus
bestioles qui n'avait jamais rien su
faire don peuvent être coupés l'egypte y
avait installé un satellite d'arrosage
civilisateur et culturelle à grande
puissance
c'était une espèce de grand moulin qui
faisaient pleuvoir sur les enfants de
shadocks dépensé nouvelles de joie du
progrès de civilisation et du bonheur en
amont d'avenir n'est ainsi tous les
matins les shadoks recevait sur le
rêviez la fine fleur des principes
civilise hâtif jbe aimez vous les uns
les autres
ne vous battez plus ne vous n'aurez plus
ça risque de vous écarter les dons pour
vous faire de mal à l'aise collision
avec le dentifrice des dons en libye le
soir vous avez des dents le lendemain
vous n'en avaient trait à l'eau pour ne
pas sûr de mal les uns les autres
les shadoks se laver soigneusement les
dons aux des dentifrices usines
[Musique]
continuent la vérité c'était pas
tellement l'atmosphère qui polluaient
deschaseaux que c'était plutôt les
shadoks qui polluent l'atmosphère
alors ils décidèrent d'arrêter de
respirer bêtement à tort et à travers
pour ne pas polluer le rêve le chat d'oc
n'avait le droit de respirer qu'une fois
par jour et pas n'importe
ensuite pour ce dépôt lui de l'extérieur
les shadoks inventaire la douche et le
bain de pieds naturellement il n'était
pas habitué l'on leur faisait très mal
de chien quelquefois même ça leur percée
bédié dans le dos ou bien la patte fondé
et j'adore qui n'en pouvait plus
pour s'entraîner à la propreté les ja
doc avait des douches spéciale qui ne
donnait qu'une goûte à la fois c'est ce
qu'on a appelé depuis les dons ces
écossais quand ils sont bien habitués
alors les shadoks sur pris d'une
frénésie et des vélos baignoire y avait
aussi des autobus un bain de pieds aux
arrêts ont planté des arbres arrosoir et
les parapluies bien entendu devaient
être obligatoirement équipés de douches
individuelles ou que les petits on ne
peut pas dire que la civilisation
château qu'avant c'est un grand pas mais
tout ça les gbe
les j'y vis de leurs satellites voyait
que les shadoks passé leur temps à pompe
et cteep avec des machins donc ça ne
pouvait pas ti civile
[Musique]
j'adore mes frères disait le moulin ne
vous fatiguez plus après p réjouissez
vous
aujourd'hui commence pour vous la
civilisation des loisirs
un ministre des loisirs et nommé des
coûts de formation loisy qu'accélérer
sont organisés de loisy du loisir il ou
elle loisy nous nous agissons la journée
de loisirs commencé dès 8 heures du
matin on loisy c'est pendant toute la
matinée
vers midi on prenait un sandwich ou
vitamine l'oise iq et on re l'oise hissé
jusque vers 6h 6h30
après le prenais des cours du soir de
loisirs pour se perfectionner la nuit
ont récupéré naturellement il y avait de
mauvais loisy soeur qui trichaient dès
que le chef de loisirs avait le dos
tourné ils se mettaient à pomper comme
des dératés cela était condamnée aux
loisirs forcés à perpétuité
ce qui était diplômé de l'école des
hautes études touristiques avaient droit
à des cabines de loisirs individuelle
munie de tous les perfectionnements les
autres les malheureux était obligé de
loisirs à la chaîne ce qui est
excessivement penny par la suite qu'on
aime dans un but humanitaire la journée
de loisirs fut réduite à vite ce n'est
que beaucoup plus tard que cet institut
et la semaine de loisirs de 40 heures
avec une tonne de tracts avec bien sûr
un mois de travail chez des parents sans
compter les pipes et les jours pompe et
notamment le jour de la fête des loisirs
vous exceptionnellement rôle oasis est
ainsi les shadoks petit à petit
perdirent l'habitude de pomper les trop
longues vacances de travail à la fin ça
les ennuyer et il était bien content
souvent de retourner à leur bureau et
leur usine à loisir et les jbe dont
leurs satellites se réjouissait les
shadoks commencé à se civiliser
bientôt ils pourraient leur apprendre le
menu et l'egypte y étaient parvenues à
un degré de civilisation telle qu'il
pouvait passer une journée entière
pratiquement sans rien fait non
seulement une journée mais même
plusieurs journées de suite pour ne pas
dire des années
[Musique]
deux autres qu'on aime il travaillait au
travail libye consistant essentiellement
à danser le menu est c'est-à-dire à pas
faire grand chose
de chaudes que non seulement elle ne
faisait rien quand il ne travaillait pas
mais il ne faisait rien non plus quand
il travaillait ce qui n'est pas à la
portée du premier venu vous avouerez
mais les shadoks ces pauvres n'en était
pas encore là huit heures de loisirs par
jour ça les fatigue et énormément les
usines à loisir devait être
soigneusement gardé sens à des shadoks
s'échapper et à les casser des cailloux
ou planter des clous dans les cours et
après une dure journée de loisirs le
chat d'oc contrer chez lui travaille à
casser des cailloux quoi planter des
couteaux libre d'ailleurs pour faire
durer le plaisir
les couches haddock étaient munis de
ressort pour ba s'enfoncer trop vite
malgré cela une bonne partie de la
planète shadoks était complètement
recouverte de clous de sang il fallait
enfoncé les clous
tous les clous
et quand il n'y avait plus de place le
chat d'oc enfoncé des clous bonne marque
pour les cailloux le shadow qui n'avait
le droit qu'à un petit caillou a quasi
par jour et 2 dont les jours de fête
comme ça leur suffisait pas je n'avais
qui allait voler la nuit
chaque caillou devait être soigneusement
gardée par un gars de cailloux mais ça
c'est un dernier parce que les shadows
creuser des trous pour aller casser les
caillots hambach en dessous
[Musique]
déjà il n'y avait plus de ce caillou
deux présentes
si ça continue et il n'y aurait bientôt
plus de planètes du tout et plus de
shadow qu'évidemment les jib y virent
qu'il était temps de leur apprendre
travaille beaucoup moins cassant comme
le menuet arrêt besoin
les jb ça nous faisait de la peine de
voir les shadows peiné comme des brutes
pour essayer de s'amuser
légis but ce n'était pas de mauvais
bougre au fond seulement ils croyaient
que la seule façon de symboliser il
était dedans c'est le menuet
alors ils envoyèrent chez les chats
d'aucune mission culturelle
interstellaire composée des meilleurs
ambassadeurs menu et east jbe
[Musique]
les jaloux très impressionné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un ministre guy menut est aussitôt nommé
les shadoks sortent leurs instruments
ils y avaient leurs tics lidar sol la
flûte de pan
le piano à percussion centrale la
bombarde d'harmonie et la bombarde à
retardement n'est ensuite les corps le
cor de chasse
le corps de pêche la corne de brume
enaco jeetoo conviendrez c'était déjà un
des instruments excessivement danser
mais en plus de ça il faut savoir que la
musique shadoks était tout à fait
spéciale il y avait quatre notes qui
d'ailleurs avait le même nom gars on
avait le gars dur
le gars mort
le gars bémol quelques mois nous enfin
il y avait le gazon mais c'était une
autre qu'on n'entendait pas on s'en
servait pour jouer de la musique pendant
les minutes de silence la musique
chandhok se jouer en 378 round
chacun d'eux comprenez 984 temps qui
touche d'ailleurs étaient des enfants
c'était très peiné en voyant soit des
menuiseries bifur positivement effrayé
et repartir dare dare est assez mal en
point il food
quant aux shadows kobo du 225e round
groupe du menuet il ne restait plus un
seul de 20 litres
les shadoks pensèrent que décidément
toutes ces danses modernes c'était plus
de leurs actes ils décidèrent qu'il
continuerait à s'amuser comme il en
avait l'habitude et partir en vacances
de travail pour se reposer
les shadoks partait en vacances de
travail dans des colonies de travail et
il s'amusait à casser des cailloux la
cadoterie shadoks étaient organisées de
la façon suivante une première équipe de
shadocks casser les cailloux aux murs ou
excessivement fin ému c'est ce qu'on
appelait le cas ça les cailloux casser
une deuxième équipe mélanger des
morceaux bien intimement à la pipe
mélangeuse c'était le ménage il était
transporté à duch ados que dans des
contrées les plus lointaines possible
la dope les équipes de vacanciers trier
les bout de caillou pour refaire les
cadeaux qu'on appelait naturellement
tous les morceaux de canne ou n'était
jamais au même endroit qui coursent y
est allé de ci de là pour retrouver les
morceaux qu'il fallait c'est mons ont
ensuite été soigneusement recoller ce
qu'on appelait leur colle à des équipes
de vérifier hier vérifier qu'il n'y
avait pas de morceaux qui manque les cas
d'où une poire faits ou les transporter
à dos à dos 12-12 guinea nakasu d'autres
équipes donnent des airs casser les
cailloux au mort sont excessivement fin
et menus c'est ce qu'on appelait leur
cas ça et le processus recommence avec
ce système les shadows passer des
vacances de travail excessivement dur et
pénible et salir a arraché comme il n'y
avait plus assez cailloux pour faire
plaisir à tous jeunes ou cassel
déshonore des autos et des visites de
broca soir à bicyclette des shadoks
cassait des bicyclettes ont faim et
menus morceaux
ces morceaux été mis en paquets et
précis pour faire des briques à
bicyclette
celle-ci transporté en automobile dans
des bicycle prix étaient des briques et
aider mais les open à bicyclette pour
retrouver les morceaux et avec tout ça
on veut fabriquer des vélos ceux ci
étaient transportés à dos j'adopte dans
d'autres cas soir et où l'erika s'est et
le processus recommence
et les vacances finies les shadoks la
mort dans l'âme retourner à leurs
loisirs en dehors de leurs heures de
sommeil et de leurs heures de loisirs
obligatoire les shadoks laborey
[Musique]
il abhorrait dans les mines de sauce
tomate pour piocher de la sauce tomate
[Musique]
il abhorrait dans les gisements de
nouilles pour faire de la nouille
concrètes et pour faire cuire tout ça
qu'ils abhorraient après comme des
brutes dans des mines à eux
je ne parlerai que pour mémoire des
pauvres enfants shadoks on envoyait
minet dans les mines de sel et de poivre
pour saler poivrer les joues yasha pas
je ne parle pas non plus des malheureux
qu'ils abhorraient dans les mines
allumettes qui servait à allumer des
cuisinières à gaz à maman que cela
serait vraiment trop triste et
l'histoire shadoks est quand même une
histoire drôle n'est-il pas vrai c'était
triste certes mais ça faisait des trous
notre problème ici n'est pas de savoir
si c'était triste parce qu'il y avait
des trous s'il y avait des trous parce
que c'était triste on a autre chose à
faire
sachez seulement que quand le chat doc
avait mangé ces nouilles ils allaient
tous et casser des cailloux
oui ils se donnaient ensuite beaucoup de
mal pour les recoller en forme de fer à
repasser ou ducasse trois lacs tenir les
nouilles
on les reconnaît aussi souvent d'hyper
cas je veux dire caselli partout les
casseroles dépassé par des bouteilles et
cinq ou six shadoks aussi par la même
occasion
mais ça c'est pas notre problème les
recolonise recoller tout ça en forme de
vélo de trottinettes d'automobiles ou
d'aéronefs
les shadoks volontaires partent est
aussitôt sur les routes tout été réduits
en menus morceaux y compris
naturellement les shadows c'est triste
mais c'est pas les plus gros détritus
c'était réutilisés sur place pour
prolonger la route vers un avenir
meilleur
mais de fil en aiguille vous comprendrez
quand même que la planète shadoks tomber
tant que nous y est allé mourir c'était
triste certes mais c'était pas le
problème à force de casser de recoller
leur casser et de rld est cassé la
planète shadoks fatalement ceux des
trous est semi n'est exempt gay
ckx matériel c'était à et se taire en un
mot comme en cent elle tombe et en
bourse mais les morceaux étaient aussi
tout aspiré par les pompes à cause de
gaulle jbe les shadoks ça les amuse
énormément de voir leurs cochonneries
inspiré et le kck cinq ans et c'était
très rigolo parce que c'est pour plaquer
en temps normal était dressée pour
fabriquer du kosovo gaulle à partir de
rien je vous laisse à imaginer ce
qu'elle fabriquait quand on les
nourrissait de cochonneries
substantielle ça faisait de la
cochonnerie l impuissance cap
le satellite gibier ont été complètement
submergées et pour la première fois les
jbe craignent
la fin des shadoks se donnait même plus
la peine de casser il va lancer
directement par dessus bord fourneaux
casseroles écumoire et tout le toutim ou
la mathématique physique
l'histoire est un jeu plus quelques
chats beaucoup aussi par la même
occasion il s'aperçut qu'il ne pouvait
parfaitement vivre sans tout ça certes
la planète était très amincie mais pour
la première fois les shadows mais chez
dgipi c'était pas pareil
certains déjà laissé apparaître des
symboles incline certains voyaient leurs
prêts s'allonge et d'autres allongés
partout pour des parts d'autres enfin
allonger japon
déjà il ne se reconnaissait plus et non
pas de partir en guerre contre les longs
chapeau et je dois dire que beaucaire
certain plaisir
fini le menu est
fini les gourmandises
finie la civilisation jbe c'était triste
espérons que d'ici demain ça s'arrangera
chez les jbe c'était la panique des
miasmes divers leur tombaient des
étoiles en général mais de la planète
shadoks ont plus particulier et ça on
crasset les pompes à cosmocom ces
dociles machine été conçu pour extraire
les plus exquises substance des vacuité
les plus vite mais dès qu alimenter
d'antivir
elle produisait les antilles substance
excessivement inefficace des musiques
devenait fuligineux et substantielle les
nourritures devenait donzy musée
calories sérieuse
on ne peut pas dire tout bonnement au
goût de renault mais c'était pas de la
faute au moulin de tous qu'ils moulay
les moulins jbe aujourd'hui c'était du
milliard sur le chat d'oc du détritus
tchador du délétère de ces machins qui
paul lua lua tiac cd composé à 90% de
gégène et à 198 pour saw ii colibacilles
killer foutait et des maladies
incurables comme la colibacilles os du
pied
laconi bassil ou joie et surtout la
colibacilles use de la tête plus connus
maintenons sous le nom de colis et b
s'il ose tout et pour les générations
futures disons que la connerie abc
l'ours s'attaque de préférence au
servait nous tondent à nîmes où évoluer
comme la pince à linge et de marteau ou
tout autre objet raisonnable tout et
d'une âme et d'un corps ça les incite à
croire qu'ils peuvent penser dit il
faudrait à s'agiter dont des directions
diverses et imaginaire comme le haut et
le bas à droite à gauche et le milieu
sans savoir précisément où est le ballon
élimine terrassé par la colle et
imbécile aux néo jbe sa personne un coup
qu'ils étaient les plus intelligents du
monde et qu'ils étaient les dieux et la
minute d'après
[Musique]
ils devinrent totalement coup et il
récupéra or malheureusement il ne s'en
aperçut repas c'est des choses qui
arrivent tous et bien oui la
civilisation jbe tombe est en
déconfiture
légis bis des confitures et des feature
[Musique]
plus de suaves musique terrassé par la
colère des silos déchets dits courait
comme des rats au foisonnement la
conduite plus grands gendarmes eux
cagibi qui pensaient un menu et guerrier
un menuet du choc un nommé château avait
crevé pas mal
s'il voulait continuer à ce jeu-là il
allait falloir qu'ils se reproduisent
or les gbe malheureusement n'avait
jamais réfléchi à la question
le professeur jbe coup dit qu'il fallait
pondre des ce mais comme l'egypte y
avait de bien trop petites pattes c'est
cela on ne pouvait pas les couvées
[Musique]
s'adonnaient d'affreuses choses
lamentables qu'on n'ose à peine vous
montrer et que nous verrons dans une
autre émission à nous l'egypte ils
décidèrent qu'il prendrait des oeufs
pleins d'à côté c'était pratiquons les
pouvait facilement et même vous pouvez
faire couvert 1,9 par un ours mais d'un
autre côté c'était pas si astucieux que
ça parce que le gie bixi sortait
obligatoirement il était plat et sujet
biplace ont tout pour nous d'être un
oeuf plat merlot beaucoup plus plat cela
va de soi
la fois d'après le fait d'être encore
plus extra plat et cetera deux socles
qu'est la deuxième ou troisième
génération la famille jbe voilà ce qu'il
veut rester une ridicule pelures
d'oignon et s'était pas tout un ado
n'est soit agi vite face soit 1 gbit
profil mais jamais les deux à la fois
alors les malheureuses bêtes et ray pour
retrouver qui sa phase qui son profil
essayer de faire un gimmick complet mais
n'y arrivent déjà mais vous pensez
sans compter que ces moitiés de gy be la
moitié du temps on les voyait pas
c'était pas pratique pour faire de la
télévision
ça continue comme ça on pourrait pas
renouveler leur contrat les jours des
jib y étaient comptés j'en ai bien peu
chers téléspectateurs
[Musique]
un matin c'était le 28 juillet 1940 13
je me souviens les shadows qui les jbe
décidèrent qu'il en avait assez
ça tombait bien vu que ce matin a
justement la fin de l'histoire était vie
la fin de l'histoire était venu et ça
leur faisait quand même pas mal de mal
de savoir qu'ils allaient mourir sont
fichés qu'on aime pas mal faut dire vu
que depuis le temps les abbés mourut
tellement de fois les uns les autres que
cette fois là aussi c'était sûr s'en
remettre mais avoue de se séparer ils
décidèrent qu'il ferait un style où ils
ont embauché réveillère a pris 2 une
feuille de papier de crayons de couleur
et trois bouteilles d'encre
quatre directeurs de télévision 6000
dessinateur scénariste et écrivain sied
plus 680 18 millions de différents
objets non encore identifiés ça a
commencé comme ça
c'était il ya très très très longtemps
ou pas tu es
ensuite on a il y avait le ciel mais
était ce le ciel à droite du ciel il y
avait la planète château elle était
complètement plate et elle penchée soit
d'un côté soit de l'eau à gauche du ciel
mais était ce vraiment le ciel il y
avait la planète jpy elle n'avait pas de
formes spéciales ou plutôt elle
changeait faim sur la planète jib il y
avait des jbe de deux sortes des gibiers
avec des pions bas qui vivait au dessus
de la planète et des gibiers avec des
pieds on roule qui vivaient de l'autre
côté et qui servait à soutenir la
planète par en dessous
sur la planète shadow qu'il y avait des
animaux qu'on appelait les shadows voici
un shadok vu de près on voit si un autre
quand il y avait trop de shadocks d'un
conte et la planète pencher les shadows
glissé il y en avait qui trompait et 7
et surtout les shadoks les shadows
qu'est l'egypte ils en eurent donc assis
au bout d'un certain temps de vivre sur
des planètes qui ne marchait pas bien
alors ils décidèrent les uns et les
autres d'aller sur la terre qui était au
nord du ciel etc avaient l'air de mieux
marcher mais était ce la paix
mais était ce le nord
[Musique]